given all of the recent talk about the
United Kingdom deciding to leave the
European Union often referred to as
brexit short for British exit from the
European Union I thought it would be
interesting to do a primer on well what
exactly is the European Union this is
going to be a high-level primer the
actual topic can get quite complex quite
fast but to understand what the European
Union even is I will draw a little line
here to represent a spectrum a spectrum
of I guess you'd say national
organizations or organizations of
nations so at this end right over here
I'll draw this is a trade bloc
this is when a group of nations get
together and say and usually say hey
let's have free trade between our
countries let's make it if we make
something in one country we want to sell
in the next that there's no tarasana and
it might include things like it's easy
to move money between one country and
other and sometimes we believe include
it's easy to move people between one
country to another and a good example of
a trade bloc especially from a North
American point of view is NAFTA north
american free trade agreement this is
the United States Mexico and Canada
having a free trade agreement you make
something in one of those countries you
want to sell on the other one you don't
have to have any any you won't have any
terrace it makes it reasonably easy to
transport goods from one country to
another and there's even some provisions
around investments and the movement of
people and why would a country want to
do this well there's a there's many
economic arguments and theories that it
increases it increases the prosperity of
all of the parties now some folks will
disagree with that and they might say on
average it might but they're definitely
going to be some losers in different
countries depending on which industries
go where but that's the rationale for
why free trade agreements exist that it
would increase the economic growth of
all involved and it will make them all
be able to participate in a larger
economic shared market now at this end
of the spectrum I'm going to talk about
when states get really close to each
other to really form a meta State to
really form a country made up of those
states and I will call this a federation
and maybe the most famous Federation
from an American point of view would be
the United States United States of
America it is made up of 50 states it
literally stands for United States of
America but those 50 states have become
so integrated that they act as one
country they act as one nation they act
as one people each of those states do
they are semi-autonomous they do have
their own governor their own legislature
their own courts
their own laws but they do also there's
also a federal government there is a
federal army federal courts there is a
president there is there is a federal
legislature and so they are so
integrated as to be one country now in
between you'll sometimes your words like
confederation or Confederacy con fed
Kahn Federation and this is a more of a
loose term there's not a strict this is
a confederation or that is not a
confederation but it's it's generally
viewed as a as looser than a federation
that the states or the countries that
are members of a confederation can opt
in or opt out that they might be
integrated in some ways and not
integrated in other ways so when we
think about the European Union which
involves which involve which for sure
involves aspects of a trade bloc it has
free trade it involves free trade
between its members it talks about the
movement of people so free movement but
it goes further than a traditional trade
bloc it goes further than something like
NAFTA it has in Russells and it has
rotating leadership it has it has
regulations and laws that often apply to
things like free trade and free movement
but it can also apply to things outside
of that there's even some integration
between militaries or I guess at minimum
you could say cooperation each of the
members have their own military and they
are independent states in their own
right but there is more integration than
you would see in something like NAFTA so
the European Union I would put it
someplace in this spectrum
right over here and depending on whom
you talk to you will get different
opinions and different people will
debate some people say well it's more
about trade and having a large shared
common market and maybe being able to
have a little bit more clout on the
world even from a foreign policy point
of view while some people will say well
no it's it seems to be moving in this
direction where it's becoming a tighter
confederation of some kind albeit with
still a lot of independence from each of
the Member States and the people who
think it's more on the right-hand side
they'll point things like well it's got
its own flag it's got an anthem you have
some military more than cooperation you
even have some integration the trend
seems to be moving from left to right
it's not only is it about trade it's
also about currency and that's where I'm
going to introduce this other concept
called the euro zone which is often
confused with the European Union and
that's because there's a lot of overlap
between the two the euro zone is the
subset of the European Union that uses
the same currency and then that currency
is called the euro this is about
currency and this is about the euro and
so once again this would move it a
little bit more to the right not only do
you have free trade and free movement of
people and and you have some regulations
and of course the member states have
representation in determining what those
regulations are but you also have most
of the European Union has a shared
currency which of course facilitates
things like free trade and free movement
but this is more than what you see in
NAFTA Mexico the United States and
Canada do not have a shared currency but
this is what this map shows us is both
the total the European Union but it also
shows that it's not exactly the same
thing as the euro zone everything we see
in blue and this pink color combined
that is the European Union the
difference between the blue and the pink
is that the blue are European members
that also use the euro as their currency
so they are members of the eurozone so
Spain and France and Germany and Italy
and and the Republic of Ireland they are
members of both the European Union and
the
eurozone while countries like the United
Kingdom and Denmark and Sweden and
Poland and I could keep going on and on
they do not currently have the euro as
their currency they have their own
currencies they have their own central
banks the the UK which is where we
started this conversation they have the
British Pound Sterling now in terms of
whether or how or whether they're going
to move to the euro it's different from
country to country countries like
countries like the UK and Denmark have
official opt outs they never had any
intention and they have opted out of
going to the euro countries like Sweden
it's not as official but it doesn't look
like they they have any intention of
going to the Euro while other countries
it's just a matter of time before they
do go to the euro and it's more of them
meeting certain economic and fiscal
thresholds so that they can enter into
the euro zone and once again why would
you want to become part of the euro zone
well if you're a country with a smaller
economy or a smaller currency or less
stable currency you say well I could
become part of a larger economic zone
I'm already part of a free trade and all
of that but with the currency it makes
it even it makes it even a stronger
thing why would you not want to do it
when you say well I have a strong enough
currency and I don't want to give
monetary policy to folks in Frankfurt
and once again I good people can argue
very good arguments on either side of
that now when you look at this map here
you might also notice that Kosovo and
Montenegro are colored in in this little
pink color and this is interesting
because they are not members of the
European Union but they have decided to
use the euro as their official currency
anyway so they're not even official
members of the eurozone but they still
use the euro and so that's why they get
their own special color here so if we go
back to brexit if we go back to the
United Kingdom leaving what are the
implications here well the first clear
implication is that their currency is
not going to change in the future of
their currency is is not going to change
they were never planning they don't use
a euro and they were never planning on
going to the euro and so they are using
the pound sterling and they will
continue to use the pound sterling
so that
kind of a no-brainer and the brexit
doesn't impact that same same currency
they're using they're using the pound
regardless of which way the brexit vote
went what the brexit vote does by taking
them out of the European Union is it
puts these things in question things
like free trade and free movement and
what regulations they will adopt or not
adopt and it doesn't mean that there
won't be free trade and there won't be
free movement or that the regulations
will change dramatically and it also
doesn't mean that that's not going to
happen what it means is it's all going
to call it's all going to be called into
question these are now going to have to
be separate negotiations between the
United Kingdom and the rest of the
European Union